bonjour et bienvenue dans le 7-8
week-end l'émission consacrée aux idées
de sorties dans le département tout de
suite à le sommaire de votre émission
l'osmothèque de versailles organise ce
samedi une conférence olfactives sur la
grande histoire de la parfumerie nous
recevrons dans quelques instants le
parfumeur jean carnet au théâtre le
spectacle pierrot lunaire une oeuvre
musicale de 1912 est programmée ce
samedi à 20h30 au théâtre de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines les détails
dans ce magazine cinéma le directeur du
grenier à sel de trappes gueule pilot
nous présentera son coup de coeur de la
semaine
il va nous parler du film ernest et
célestine à long métrage qui passera
dans sa salle ce week-end et plus nous
parlerons également de l'atelier
conférence sur le manga programmé ce
samedi à la médiathèque anatole-france
de trappes
on commence ce magazine par un
rendez-vous l'osmothèque de versailles
vous propose ce samedi à 14h30 une
conférence olfactives pour découvrir la
grande histoire de la parfumerie pour
nous parler de cet événement nous
recevons sur ce plateau le fondateur de
l'osmothèque et parfumeur jean pierre
léaud
c'est un plaisir de vous recevoir sur ce
plateau bonjour bon jeu alors tout
d'abord avant de parler de cette
conférence nous allons parler de
l'osmothèque pourquoi avoir créé cette
hausse motech à versailles
cette hausse modeste et tout d'abord
conservatoire de parfois le nom de
mottec bien d'en vouloir quelque chose
de tout à fait particulier et qu'il ne
soit propre à nous et pourquoi l'avoir
fait à versailles parce que c'était la
seule opportunité qu'on avait trouvé que
j'avais trouvé à l'époque dont localiser
donc ce set ce conservatoire
parce que l'idée avait été jugée
peut-être un petit peu farfelue pour
certains nous avaient dit c'est mission
impossible de retrouver des parfums
anciens n'est parfait a perdu comme on
les appelle surtout que ça a beaucoup
évolué au cours du temps et que donc il
fallait d'abord retrouver trace de ses
parfums les refaire que l'homme à
l'origine est ensuite donc pouvoir donc
de présenter au public et au public en
public mais aussi aux professionnels de
la parfumerie et donc l'idée on a pu le
dire c'est une grande base de données en
fait pour le parfum on peut dire ça
absolument c'est une base de données
quelque chose d'unique au monde donc
c'est un
une collection de parfums on a refait
pour une bonne part plus également tous
les parfums actuelle donc ils sont
accumulés on a aujourd'hui quelque chose
comme 3800 parfait indifférent mais là
la grande part si l'on peut dire à part
la plus importante de l'osmothèque c'est
des parfums historique
voilà et quand même visiteurs viennent à
l'osmothèque chaque année ou dans l'est
dans la mise en plis sain je crois de
plus en plus dans les 5000 on a commencé
timidement il ya un peu plus d'un quart
de siècle
et ça s'amplifie on note souvent des
problèmes de place donc demain une
conférence sur l'histoire car fin est
organisée
quel sera le programme de cette
conférence c'est une séance pratiquement
classique c'était l'histoire du parfum
de l'antiquité à nos jours
et donc il y aura l'évocation d'un
certain nombre de parfums à commencer
par le plus ancien qu'on ait pu refaire
si le parfum royal du 1er siècle
et puis après vous avez toute
l'évolution de la parfumerie qui en fait
donc était liée à l'histoire tout court
pas simplement l'histoire du parfum
c'est vieux comme le monde sa a suivi
l'évolution du monde et finalement honda
parfumerie contemporaine
c'est quelque chose qui remonte
simplement 150 ans donc il y aurait une
trentaine de parfums qui seront à peu
près présenter un oui à ce que chaque
séance oui c'est une trentaine de
parfums quelques matières premières
aussi pour expliquer cette évolution pu
faire sentir des produits
donc ils marchent que la parfumerie et
du coup l'objectif c'est de faire sentir
au public ses parfums oui on est resté
le maillot différent ce classique avec
avec des diapos notamment pour le nom
c'est vrai travail ont fait sentir au
vent ludiques ont fait sortir grâce à
des mouillettes de petites languettes de
buvards qui sont trempés le parfum est
donc on peut emporter chez soi que les
gens emporte chez soi parce que
finalement c
languette de papier buvard ses
mouillettes conserve le parfum pendant
plusieurs jours et donc on peut encore
mieux apprécier après chez soi
donc après la séance et réfléchir à tout
ce qu'on a dit auparavant et donc la
conférence dure 2h30 si je me tourne
vers 2h à 2h30 c'est un choix vraiment
de programmer cette conférence sur deux
heures et demie pour que les gens
puissent nous envoient leur temps pour
analyser les on avait programmé des
sillons sur une heure une heure et demie
sa part et c'est suffisant mais ça a été
vite dépassé parce que finalement c'est
pas des conférences magistrales devront
discuter le public qu'on dialogue et
donc les gens sont même sens sans le
vouloir spontanément ils posent des
questions et donc on y répond dans toute
la mesure du possible sans bien sûr
occulter le reste de la présentation est
ce qui fait que il faut compter une
moyenne de 2 heures et souvent un peu
plus et donc les intervenants ce sont
des professionnels
nous sommes tous des professionnels il y
a un certain nombre d'anciens comme moi
et donc il ya aussi maintenant des gens
qui sont encore en activité demain par
exemple il ya thomas fontaine qui est
l'actuel parfumeur créateur de jean
patou qui m'a remplacé chez patou moi
j'étais pendant 33 ans j'ai vu cette
fonction chez dans cette même maison et
donc on peut dire que ces parfums ce
sont des chefs-d'oeuvre vraiment ils
sont pas tout seul il y a des grands
chefs-d'oeuvre de la parfumerie on s'est
attaché à les retrouver à les refaire et
en fait on considère qu'ils ne nous
appartiennent pas et nous sont confiés
nous sommes les gardiens des trésors si
l'on peut dire est donc long s'est
attaché à essayer de retrouver la
plupart de ses parfums perdu et c'est
parti d'une idée que j'avais su à
l'époque parce que le temps j'étais
parfumeurs créateurs souvent je suis un
parfum les gens les sentait me disais
oui c'est bon parfois on dit ça me
rappelle un parfum que ma mère ma grand
mère portait des choses comme ça on fait
toujours bien sûr des des références à
des quelque chose d'ancien et souvent on
me disait un mais vous savez autrefois
il y avait un parfum de ce genre mais
c'était meilleur qu'aujourd'hui
et alors comme le parfum c'est quelque
chose qui se conservent malsch bon se
conservent pas on était très gêné parce
que moi même je n'avais pas senti ses
parfums et donc je voulais vraiment les
retrouver puisqu'on me disaient qu'ils
étaient très bons et voilà donc ça a été
le cheminement de l'équipe de
l'osmothèque nous étions une dizaine de
parfumeur à nous est penché donc sur ce
travail et on a réussi donc l'événement
de demain s'adresse plutôt à des
familles plutôt à des connaisseurs il y
à des connaisseurs il ya de vrais
amateurs de parfums mais non je pense
que la plupart des gens oui peuvent
s'impliquer là dedans d'une manière
générale ça ça va être quand même
beaucoup plus à des adultes là des
enfants si l'on peut dire une ou faisons
des séances spécialement pour les
enfants aussi en fait de tout quand on
fait de tout mais enfin la base même
c'est que même si vous voulez le côté
historique de ses parfums d'où l'on
vient et où on va merci à vous d'être
passé sur ce plateau c'était un plaisir
de vous recevoir
je le rappelle la conférence sur la
grande histoire du parfum est programmée
ce samedi à partir de 14h30 à
l'osmothèque de versailles coup de
projecteur à présent sur une oeuvre
musicale
pierrot lunaire de schoenberg ne cesse
de fasciner les artistes cette oeuvre
musicale de 1912 prend une nouvelle fois
l'aide à l'aide d'un exemple l'ensemble
de marinade japonaise première
représentation de ce spectacle de
création samedi 16 janvier au théâtre de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines
un reportage de sephora namani et de
patrick jacques de dixmude dans une
maison de thé au japon pierrot est
amoureux de colombine label geisha mais
par crainte du terrible cassandre ils ne
peuvent s'aimer qu'en cachette
pierrot lunaire de schoenberg est une
oeuvre musicale composée en 1912 elle
est revisitée au théâtre de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines samedi 16
janvier
l'âme du spectacle essentiellement est
tout d'abord c'est la musique celle de
schoenberg arnold schönberg pierrot
lunaire une oeuvre fabuleuse écrite en
1912 et qui garde encore tout son
mystère toute sa modernité
on n'a pas fini de l'explorer on va dire
emotionnellement artistiquement dans son
exécution
la nouveauté c'est la dramaturgie c'est
l'ajout d'une histoire et de sa
représentation par des marionnettes de
type boudera coup c'est à dire des
marionnettes japonaise dans une
scénographie days pour donner forme
vivante à cette oeuvre 4 marionnettes
japonaise du théâtre baudrac ou
s'animeront au premier plan guide et
chacune par trois marionnettistes un
travail de coordination pour arriver à
donner deux concerts un même souffle à
la marionnette
a les qualités pour être de bons
marionnettiste c'est avant tout je pense
d'être comédien c'est à dire de savoir
cerner un personnage c'est à dire de
pouvoir entrevoir tout ce que le
personnage peut faire en réponse à ses
partenaires aussi d'être d'avoir un
excellent entraînement physique pour
lorsqu'on est trois sur une manne
marionnettes avoir la même respiration
et transmettre la même impression
émotions deux concerts sur un même corps
qu'on anime au deuxième plan les
musiciens et la chanteuse servent de fil
directeur à la narration du comte de
pierrot formé par un ensemble de 21
points également
l'instrumentation est singulière avec
l'utilisation du spray shoegazing le
strech par kazan c'est donc
effectivement une façon de déclamer le
texte qui est un peu chantée mais pas
tout à pêche solberg avait ainsi inscrit
des hauteurs de notes ne s'agit surtout
pas de le chanter initialement c'était
une commande pour une grande amie à lui
une certaine madame zemin qui avait
l'habitude de réciter des poèmes
accompagnés par un piano donc schönberg
a accédé à sa demande est elle donc
créer c'est une histoire avec cette
difficulté
effectivement du stress cazin oui il
faut dire sans chanter et chanter 110
un spectacle de création qui conjugue
expressionnisme allemand et poésie
japonaise à découvrir pour sa première
au théâtre de saint-quentin-en-yvelines
le samedi 16 janvier
un rendez-vous à ne pas manquer pour les
amateurs de manga ce samedi à 14h en
ateliers conférences sur ces bandes
dessinées japonaises est programmée à la
médiathèque anatole-france de trappes
pour nous parler de cet événement nous
recevons juliette garcia bibliothécaire
à la médiathèque et experte en manga
bonjour alors cet événement et pour les
fans de manga ou c'est vraiment tout
public
c'est plutôt pour les fans en tout cas
pour ceux qui essayent de dessiner des
mangas ou vous de créer des scénarios
mais c'est ouvert à tous donc pour les
enfants oui c'est ouvert à tous plutôt à
partir de 11 ans et tout le monde est le
bienvenu il reste de la place
voilà mais c'est plutôt pour donner des
astuces des conseils à des gens qui ont
envie de dessiner des mangas et c'est
gratuit c'est gratuit vous inscrire
téléphonez à la médiathèque
tentez votre chance le jour même mais
c'est quand même mieux de téléphoner
donc l'animation sera proposé avec
l'association quelle joie c'est une
structure spécialisée dans les mangas
oui en fait c'est une association de
passionnés qui a pour but d'aider les
autres passionnés des délais les gens à
faire leur mandat donc il propose un
forum de discussion des tutoriels
il propose des trams et il propose plein
des dents fait à la réalisation de ce
moment car ils ont un comité éditorial
pour éditer des mangas visible sur
internet il y en a quelques-uns qui sont
édités en formule papier et ils ont donc
des auteurs aidé mais tout ça c'est ce
sont des amateurs et bientôt il me
semble c'est lé 23 24 il propose les
douze heures en 24 jours 23 24 janvier
ils proposent les 12 heures de la bd
amateurs c'est pas comme c'est pas un
concours mais c'est un défi en fait où
douze planches en 12 heures chacun sur
le même thème et donc ce week-end donc
il y aura plusieurs ateliers notamment
en ateliers pour travailler cette
technique
donc venez sans donc en fait c'est
damien chazelle qui est un auteur qui
s'appelle cd dame qui vient et qui
propose de répondre aux questions toutes
les questions et d'aider à résoudre les
problèmes et perfectionner donc sa
technique notamment les expressions
faciales le scénario vraiment donner des
astuces
et en même temps donner une vue une vue
générale sur le manga ce pour quoi on a
appelé ateliers conférences et du coup
ces ateliers durent tout l'après midi
tout l'après-midi de 14 ans on doit
suivre l'atelier du début jusqu'à la fin
où on peut arriver en courant le mieux
quand on est passionné ça passe vite
donc il y en a qui est proposée ce
samedi et l'autre le mercredi 27
on peut venir juste juste à l'un ou à
l'autre et c'est quoi l'objectif de cet
événement c'est de renforcer encore plus
du coup cette culture manga à saint
quentin en yvelines c'est ça l'objectif
c'est plutôt de répondre à une demande
le manga prend de plus en plus de place
dans nos collections bande dessinée ça
va prendre plus en plus de place dans la
vie en général on les dessins animés
sur internet et c'est donc le mois de
janvier c'est le mois de la bd dans les
médiathèques donc que ça serait dommage
que de ne pas consacrer une animation
pour ce genre qui a tant de succès du
coup cette animation sincère vous disais
justement aux droits de la bd en
exactement cela bd on a appelé la bd
dans tous ses états et dans toutes les
médiathèques il y aura des animations bd
il ya d'autres ateliers 1 autour de la
caricature un autour de la bd plus que
plus traditionnelle dans d'autres
médiathèque
il ya des expositions des petits
ateliers qui sont sous l'angle du monde
du manga aussi un samedi qu est ce qu on
lit axée sur la bd et c'est donc tout le
mois de janvier nos animations
médiathèque ce sont centrés sur la bande
dessinée est donc vous l'avez dit reste
quelques places impôts pour l'atelier
avant il reste des places pour ce samedi
16 et pour mercredi 27
merci à vous d'être passé sur ce plateau
bon courage pour organisation de cet
événement on souhaite lier à beaucoup de
monde
du coup pour cet atelier manga on passe
maintenant notre rubrique littérature en
direction à présent le pavé du canal
comme chaque semaine la librairie vous
fait découvrir un nouveau roman
cette semaine zoom sur charlotte de
david foenkinos et de charlotte salomon
à une un livre paru aux éditions
gallimard qui a remporté deux prix
littéraires en 2014
écoutez charlotte de david foenkinos et
a reçu deux prix littéraires en 2014 le
prix renaudot et le prix goncourt des
lycéens
c'est donc pas une nouveauté il ressort
cette année pour noël en version
illustrée donc avec les
et toiles de charlotte salon en fait à
la suite de la parution de son roman
david foenkinos eu beaucoup de demandes
de la part d'électeurs qui avaient
besoin en fait d'avoir une image
associée à l'histoire de cette jeune
juive donc un petit rappel sur
l'histoire de charlotte donc charlotte
c'est salomon faisait partie des sphères
intellectuelles de berlin la seconde
guerre mondiale à l'arrivée des nazis
elle fuit vers la france pendant cette
période elle va rencontrer l'amour de sa
vie
et alors qu'elle est installée dans le
sud elle répond à la demande des
allemands de se faire répertorier pour
tous les juifs
et c'est comme ça qu'elles se retrouvent
en camps d'extermination donc se sentant
menacée elle a donc confié toutes ses
oeuvres à un médecin et c'est donc grâce
à lui qu'on peut avoir aujourd'hui une
version illustrée du roman de david
foenkinos
comme chaque semaine un programmateur
des civils nous présente son coup de
coeur aujourd'hui nous avons le plaisir
de recevoir sur son plateau à gatineau
le responsable du cinéma le grenier à
sel de trappes
bonjour bonjour alors aujourd'hui votre
coup de coeur dessiné au film ernest et
célestine on regarde la bande annonce le
grand méchant quand il se réveille et
qu'est ce que le grand méchant pour la
petite soul tout cru
c'est comme ça qu'ils préfèrent mais
surtout les six michon voici célestine
voilà son monde celui d'en bas
dans lequel elles se sentent abandonnés
voici voilà sa vie celle d'or dans
laquelle il se sent mal aimé
ils vivent dans tout le monde que tout
oppose mais aujourd'hui tout est sur le
point de changer
yann pineau pourquoi ce film a retenu
votre attention
alors c'est très simple c'est le rôle
que l'on ne voit pas beaucoup dans nos
cinémas c'est le travail que l'on fait
avec les scolaires tout le travail
d'éducation au cinéma et pourtant nous
c'est notre coeur de métier depuis plus
de 30 ans donc on peut avoir
l'impression qu'on avait fermé tout le
temps aux journées mais en fait on est
tout le temps ouvert et on marche du
matin jusqu'au soir sans arrêt parce
qu'on travaille énormément sur
l'éducation au cinéma et ce film-là
ernest et célestine comme plusieurs
autres films dans l'année sont proposées
aux écoles donc les écoles viennent dans
notre salle voit ce film sur grand écran
et travaille dessus donc à des documents
pédagogiques il ya aussi tout un
accompagnement en salle en classe et
donc là ce sont des films que les
enfants ont vu et des films que les
enfants ont travaillé
hélas pour l'on propose c'est que les
enfants puissent le montrer à leurs
parents pour montrer tout ce qu'ils ont
appris et que les enfants qui étaient
apprenant deviennent ceux qui
transmettent donc le week-end dernier
dimanche dernier nous avons passé il dit
l'extraterrestre donc en 1900 qui a été
fait en 1982 l'internet et célestine
mais il y aura d'autres films dans
l'année dont le kid de chaplin
et plein d'autres films dont il ya tout
un programme à découvrir chez nous donc
l'idée c'est que les enfants emmènent
leurs parents au cinéma pour regarder un
ferry que s'amuser ça mais surtout
qu'ils montrent qu'ils lors qu'il leur
montre le film et qu'il aura elle
reparle après dans les deux cinémas à la
maison ça n'est pas forcément de ce
qu'on voit à la télé mais aussi des
expériences peuvent avoir à l'école
c'est quelque chose d'assez incroyable
pour ce pour ce film on remarque qu'il
ya beaucoup d'humour dans ce film il ya
beaucoup d'humour et ça c'est aussi une
fable
c'est vraiment vous avez vu les images
vous avez entendu la musique on voyage
vraiment dans 1 pt dans un pays
imaginaire c'est un très beau voyage
et c'est une femme mais qui est aussi un
petit peu politique un petit peu
sensible et très moderne et vous
conseille à partir de quel âge ce film
du coup pilotage composé à partir de 4
ans et les enfants qui l'ont vu au
cinéma auront à partir de 4 ans ont vu
avec l'école
donc nous allons parler également du
gros événement qui va qui va arriver la
semaine prochaine du coup dans votre
cinéma c'est le festival télérama
est-ce que vous pouvez nous présenter ce
festival oui alors pour nous c'est une
grande grande première puisque festival
télérama ça existe depuis des années
mais ça fait des années qu'on y
postulent qu'on essaye de participer et
que l'on n'est pas propre a sélectionné
cette année c'est la première fois qu'on
y participe
alors je ne dois pas préciser que c'est
un festival qui organisé par le magazine
télérama par l'association française des
cinémas d'art et d'essai l'afcai est
donc en partenariat avec bnp paribas sa
vous le verrez par tous les logos et est
donc le but du
dupré festival c'est la reprise de
meilleurs films art et essai de l'année
donc on reprend tous les films qui ont
été sélectionnés par le festival
donc il ya des films très connu et des
faits un peu moins connus du coup il ya
des films qui ont trait déjà très très
bien marché birdman par exemple birdman
évidemment yahia vous dit allen aussi
milliers d'autres films qui sont aussi
très beaucoup moins connu un peu plus
intime mais que tout le monde envie de
mettre en avant et qui conte était donc
s'utiliser sélectionnés par la rédaction
de télérama et donc on s'est réparti
avec le ciné 7 on s'est réparti des
films ya seize films dans la sélection
on peut pas tout passé au grenier à sel
parce qu'on n'a qu'une seule elancourt
balle tous les passés non plus donc
c'est très bien on sait les répartit
ainsi on vous propose la totalité de la
sélection dans nos deux salles donc vous
aurez donc le wifi cette jeune fille
d'accord il y aurait pas dû pro chez
vous le piège à la fièvre à mustang la
loi du marché l'accord taxi téhéran
l'homme irrationnelle marguerite fatima
et backrooms qui est sorti cette semaine
et du coup les tarifs sont également
très avantageux pour les spectateurs
alors il y à un tarif très avantageux
qui est de 3 euros 50
la petite condition c'est d'acheter le
magazine de récupérer le petit papier
cadre magazine de remplir son nom prénom
de donner à la caisse et en échange nous
vous donnons le fameux pass télérama et
à partir de là vous pouvez aller à
toutes les séances du festival à 3,050
et donc c'est une initiative peut être
que vous aller reconduire l'année
prochaine vous allez demander à le
reconduire leur initiative oui oui bon
compte ont compté repostuler l'année
prochaine mais c'est pas gagné
ok merci beaucoup merci beaucoup del
pino merci à vous dépasser ce plateau on
passe à présent donc aux autres sorties
de la semaine il ya du choix dans les
salles obscures
ça m'a beaucoup plu comme fils parce que
c'est un sujet qui était très tabou à
l'époque début des années 50
heureusement les choses ont changé et
mais je pense pas que c'est un film pour
tout le monde résume mouvement
c'est un film très très beau et on se
demande
bon c'était l'époque c'était comme ça
mais il ya beaucoup de gens qui ont raté
leur vie parce que il y avait des
interdits et voilà il retrace vraiment
le début de rocky balboa soit le double
3 4 il ya vraiment c'est vachement entre
l'acteur principal et rookie en question
c'est bien filmé en fait c'est beaucoup
de plans séquences qui sont super
intéressant dans les scènes de boxe et
et c'est super intensive en fait on est
scotché pendant tout le génie bah y'a
des moments de franche rigolade
depuis ben c'est assez dur aussi
de voir la dureté de ce milieu même si
c'est une satire après cette page cinéma
on passe au rendez vous sportifs du
week-end dans le département dans cette
rubrique sport on prend tout de suite la
direction du tennis-club de la verrière
le 13e open de tennis de la ville s'est
ouvert ce week-end au parc philippe
cousteau pour cette édition 2016 150
joueurs venus principalement de la ville
nouvelle se sont inscrits pour
participer à la compétition
le tableau masculin compte 100 joueurs
âgés de 15 à 69 ans
chez les dames une cinquantaine de
joueuses se sont inscrits au tournoi en
écoute le président du club et
organisateur maurice et c'est souvent
les secondes séries qui viennent marquer
des points pour être pour être prof de
tennis il faut justement être seconde
série et les
et enfin les jeunes qui veulent qu'ils
souhaitent être professionnel finalement
et essayer de marquer des points en
début de saison
comme si le début de saison au mois de
janvier c'est bon à prendre
le week-end les premiers échanges débute
à 9h et se termina à 20 heures je vous
rappelle que le tournoi se clôture le
dimanche 31 janvier on passe au rugby
les rugbymans des équipes fédérales du
département fouleront à nouveau les
pelouses aux ce week-end dans la poule
une plaisir leader du classement reçoit
le 4e dunkerque dimanche à 15 heures au
stade robert barran les hommes de jean
miss doivent l'emporter pour conserver
la tête et ne compte qu'un seul petit
point d'avancé sur le deuxième ris
orangis son dauphin la rencontre promet
d'être spectaculaire
toujours en rugby à plaisir joue pour la
montée alors que versait lutte pour sa
survie dans ce championnat de fédérale 3
et versailles et dernier du classement
reçoivent epernay ce dimanche à 15
heures dans leur stade de porchefontaine
la rencontre semble perdue d'avancé et
permis troisième du championnat avec 21
points d'avance sur versailles
un gouffre mais on ne sait jamais en
rugby des îles loi peuvent toujours
renversés à la vapeur
c'est la fin de cette fuite ce week-end
la merci de l'avoir suivi je vous
retrouve lundi pour le 7-8 sport très
bon week-end sur tv fil 78